this is what we sort of call i guess a
friday afternoon experiment we thought
we would uh
just suspend this thing and then prick
it with a sharp knife a friday afternoon
experiment isn't an experiment you do
when you've got you've got an idea for
something that may work maybe a bit
crazy here two of my colleagues
john middleton
on the left and oleg makarovski on the
right one
two
three
he's just pierced the balloon there he's
just burst it so you can see immediately
the skin of the balloon peels back
and releases the water so that because
this bond number is so large the water
is going to drop under gravity so yes so
at this point i joined in the fun
and i've been playing around
in my research with putting
high voltages on water droplets
to in fact get them to burst so a water
droplet if you put a large enough
electrostatic charge on a water droplet
electrostatic forces between the charges
are competing with the surface tension
so those charges are wanting to
essentially get away from each other and
expand the shape of the droplet and
above a critical
amount of charge amount of electric
electric charge on the droplet
the droplet will burst we had this big
voltage source in the lab so i just
wondered what happens if we put 30 000
volts onto a big globe of water this is
exactly a friday afternoon experiment
what's going to happen if we poke this
with 30 000 volts and just just watch
what happens under a high speed camera
so there's 25 000 volts on the end of
that scalpel blade and i'm holding i'm
holding the other end with some gloves
and i'm holding it well back because i
don't want to get a belt off this the
electric field at that very sharp tip
gets large enough that it starts
stripping the electrons off the uh the
molecules the air molecules and it
starts what's called ionizing the air so
the air becomes electrically conductive
and this is where you see a spark and in
this case although you can't see it on
this uh on this video there is a little
spark between the um between the scalpel
blade and the balloon and you can
actually hear it you can hear this wine
is a kind of squealing noise
did you hear that and that's the air
breaking down this is the noise is
starting to heat up the air and it's
like causing the air to vibrate and
causing the air to scream effectively
so then it goes bang we didn't really
expect the big mass of water to fission
because it's too much we need a much
larger voltage to get the big mass of
water to split what we wanted to find
was what happened to the little droplets
with the little droplets have enough
charge on them to start fishing
themselves but it does look like the
small droplets are moving away
quicker from the big mass of water in
this case than they are with the
uncharged case and this is because the
big droplet has a charge on it the
little droplets have the uh like charge
on it so in this case it's a positive
charge on the big droplet another
positive charge on the little droplets
so that positive charge is repelling and
it's causing the little droplets to
accelerate away from the the big mass of
water
okay
yeah i could see it melting
so in this case i remember having to uh
to jab the balloon quite hard so i was
poking it and getting some resistance
from the scalpel blade
but the balloon didn't burst at the
point of the scalpel blade quite
peculiarly in this case so what happens
is
so as i was pushing the scalpel blade
into the rubber
this is what happens
bang so it breaks from the top this time
it breaks from the point where
it's been tied up with string
and then finally it breaks on the point
of the scalpel blade
and it forms this kind of really
beautiful looking sort of like mushroom
structure or jellyfish type shape so
what we think is happening in this case
is that they've made contact with the
balloon with the scalpel so the balloon
is charging up and at this point there's
a large electric field developing so you
get a large electric fields where
there's a sharp point so we're getting
some electric current now through the
top part of this balloon just through
this string the balloon and the string
was a little bit wet by this point i
think this is what happens
this is the electric current that's
bursting the balloon we've got a big
electric field at the top and it's
bursting the balloon at this point now
this is where the highest electric field
is on that balloon you get the highest
electric fields where there's a sharp
point what happens now is that then that
unlike the other the previous case
what happens is that this the top part
of the
the water here inside the balloon is
then accelerated by the breaking balloon
you can see it's being accelerated hard
down towards the rest of the water and
causing these fantastic ripples these
waves on the surface and then this is
continuing out down so there's the water
that we've accelerated at the top from
the balloon bursting in this way he's
now accelerating out towards the bottom
and creating this great sort of mushroom
effect it is good fun and uh i guess
something we quite would have wanted to
to kind of repeat this several times to
make sure this is a repeatable
phenomenon we so well we repeated it
twice
did the same thing did it again probably
the charge may well have had some
influence the charge went to the top
that put additional strain on the um on
the balloon at the top and of course
this is that top is bearing all the
weight and so perhaps the weight
combined with the charge and the strong
electric feels the top
cause it the fracture there and then
bang it goes and you this is you get
this beautiful wave coming down through
the balloon this top part is
accelerating hard now compared to the
rest of the water and it comes straight
through the bottom that's even better
that's that's fantastic this shape
we took precautions by the way when we
were charging this that richard hill was
wearing a pair of rubber gloves and over
that he had felt gloves and he was
standing also on a good insulator
because by the time we were breaking
these balloons yeah they're quite a lot
of water on the floor we've got two
experiments now in which we've done
bursting the balloon with high voltage
with charge
so now we want to see what happens
without charge so this is kind of this
is the sort of scientific method we're
now starting to see what variables are
involved without charge i'm having to
stab the balloon quite hard i remember
having to poke the balloon pretty pretty
hard
and it bursts not at the top as with the
charge so we're not getting this big
electric field because we've got no
charge on it now bursting in quite a
different way
now the balloon the water is just is
falling as one big mass it's not forming
this kind of jellyfish shape anymore we
had a relatively small amount of time to
do the experiments so we're trying to
get data but just to see that mushroom
thing being reproduced twice i think we
can try and follow that up now and
understand it better we've got some
reproducible results it's a beautiful
shape it's rather elegant so can we now
just use the simple equations of
hydrodynamics and explain that behavior
including the charge of course and
gravity
it's it's a very nice result and totally
unexpected point that way so that the
sharpness put it flat if you like so
just come in from the side when you
think it's got a good bit of momentum so
now now we're just trying everything
that we can try we've got a few minutes
left with brady and his high speed
camera so we just want to try something
we're just trying to try anything
so the next thing we try is spinning it
so we want to spin up the water and see
if we've got if you've got some water
with some spinning round it's got some
angular momentum before it bursts what
happens as it's going to burst so we've
drawn some marks on the surface of the
balloon here so that when we play the
video back we can work out how fast the
balloon is spinning so uh yeah so we've
got a little picture of lawrence there
as well to to uh to use as a mark for uh
working out how fast the balloon is
spinning we've been doing work on
spinning in our levitation system we've
been doing work on spinning water
droplets and that turned out to be quite
interesting because as we spin up the
droplet the shape of the droplet changes
from spherical to first of all something
like
a rugby bowler if you like american
football
and then it forms a sort of three
cornered hat shape the physics of this
has been studied from a theoretical
point of view for over 100 years and
they've been experiments up in the space
station on on spinning droplets but it
turned out as well that uh
our results were some interest to black
hole physicists because black holes have
this several properties they've got mass
charge
and angular momentum what we've thought
to do is a very crude experiment so that
the problem is
you know inside that balloon's got a lot
of water it's got a fairly large mass in
the time
we had how could we spin it up well the
obvious thing to do was to
to sort of turn the balloon round and
round and round and twist it we pricked
it with our with our blade again and
just to see what happens
okay
i had no idea what happened then yeah so
you can see it was rotating fairly
rapidly at this point about one
revolution a second i think i seem to
remember so it's rotating quite fast it
just doesn't look so fast on the high
speed camera
so it's still it's still spinning it's
hard to see if there's much difference
to the other one to be honest there's a
kind of a cavity there where i've
stabbed it and i suppose it does form a
sort of slightly different shape to the
one that was
stationary it's starting the water is
becoming it's flying out and the action
of the centripetal force or the
centrifugal force depending on what your
reference frame is so we want to try it
again we want to see if it is
reproducible not just some kind of
one-off some fluke of the experiment so
here's lawrence we're trying it again
yeah so he's kind of testing the waste
of it to see see if the
string at the top would hold the weight
of the balloon
got it
but now it becomes not an experiment in
physics this becomes an experiment in
biology to see what the reaction time of
a human human being is now i wasn't
bouncing i was just trying to see if it
could
if it would hold under its own weight
yeah he's going to start stepping back
any second now so he's starting the
messages got through to his head that
now he's going to get very wet any
second now
he's going to
i think he's still not realized
there we go so he's now starting to step
back so this a good one two seconds
after the uh the balloon is burst the
messages got through
to through the uh from his eyes into his
brain and now now he sent the message to
the rest of his body to move away
because he's gonna get wet
so
i'm not sure my reaction times would be
any better than that i think that's
pretty good reaction time
now i see the pictures again sitting
down at the desk yeah it's so it's so
clear that we ought to repeat it but
maybe we can have to come back to you
and do get you to do a bit more filming
and
be great we can write a paper together
instead of doing these youtube videos
as well as doing these youtube videos
will i be a co-author of course you will
brady you
you'll be probably the harren goes
before hill
maybe you help us write it you can be
first author
but he's amazed us before oh yeah i know
but no no you're a leader no no no i'm
no no no no maybe we should write the
book before we argue about authorship
maybe we want to figure it out before we
argue about authorship that's always the
right thing to do
that too